[Music]
welcome to the QuickStart tutorial for
Cloud endpoints let's get started using
Cloud endpoints by activating the cloud
shell in our console we'll download the
project code to our instance if we take
a look at the scripts directory we'll
see that we've got a couple of scripts
in there let's start by running deploy
API Sh
this script will deploy an API included
in the project files to Cloud endpoints
next let's deploy the API back-end by
executing deploy app by Sh this will
create an app engine flexible
environment to host the API back-end and
deploy our sample API to App Engine to
see our API in action
we'll run query API sh this command
takes one argument a three-letter
Airport code for example if we answer a
WR our API returns Newark Liberty
International Airport cool
we've just deployed and tested an API
and endpoints once we have an API
deployed we can also track API activity
and gain insight into our users and
usage web stackdriver logging in order
to do that first let's enable the
service control API on our project
now let's generate some activity to work
with the generate traffic that Sh script
will generate requests to our API for
five minutes that will give us plenty of
data to check out metrics for once
traffic has been generated we can check
out the endpoint services page right off
the bat we've got visibility into the
number of requests per second 500 errors
and latency we can check out the logs
for the methods of our API through this
link at the bottom of the page we just
deployed our API and started generating
data so there aren't that many errors to
be seen but as you can see every request
to our API is logged with details like
timestamp of the request the method
called and the HTTP response code and
that's it that's how easy it is to get
setup with Cloud endpoints to deploy
your very own API
[Music]